this is snake I love the snake this is
snake
what is Metal Gear Solid I think Metal
Gear Solid is like the first proper ass
attempt to make a movie in a video game
Snake
you said that love could bloom on the
battlefield
just pushing the boundaries of gaming in
ways that nobody else was doing
especially at that time Metal Gear Solid
I thought was way ahead of its time with
how cinematic it was
what are you trying to say Neta elements
like psychomance is reading your memory
card
[Applause]
[Music]
you know nobody else is thinking at that
level the critics agree Metal Gear Solid
is an absolute Masterpiece I think it's
one of the most iconic video games ever
made
if not the most iconic video game made
the best reason yet
to station and another game that kind of
defined the PlayStation era one of the
contenders for the greatest all-time
video games ever right
foreign
my first memory of Metal Gear Solid was
my friend Andrew bringing it over and
pitching it to me as like this cool
secret agent game
[Music]
and then me instantly being blown away
by it
liquid that was the first time I played
anything like that there was nothing
anywhere near that at the time
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Metal Gear Solid made by Konami in 1998
directed by Blockbuster genius Prophet
hideo Kojima
is being like hey video games they're a
nice start but let's say we give them
like a good shove along
it was waiting for someone to kill me
foreign
[Music]
it is Cinema made playable
set me free
The Sniper Wolf boss battle post-def
cutscene and that whole you know snake
can love blue on the battlefield
it humanized this character who
initially just seemed like a seductress
assassin For Hire it just gave her a lot
more depth and it made you like
sympathize with the villain everyone's
here now Metal Gear Solid will always be
the first game that ever made me cry
specifically the final battle with
Sniper Wolf that moment messed me up
that's the moment where the game just
goes from like oh yeah this is action
too oh my God I need to reevaluate my
life
it's so good I loved it
goodbye
these moments of vulnerability that he
displays maybe it's time for someone
else and that he invites Someone Like
You
maybe that's the real way to live
that was so not what you'd expect from a
dude who is literally going around
murdering an entire Island's worth of
goons it was the more human stuff that I
really love about metal
gears
at its core metal gear solid is a
stealth
Espionage tactical action video game
basically you're to stop a terrorist
group who has threatened to activate
metal gear which is a nuclear weapon
play the role of Solid Snake and you are
sent in to solve a problem but that
problem then has so many layers to it oh
you're wrong the threat of nuclear war
isn't gone in fact it's greater than has
ever been
a nuclear weapon represents potentials
outside the concepts of Conventional
Weapons
your solid you actually have a story
that might have a more meaningful
message to chew on that still would have
gone completely over the heads of most
of the children playing it he suffered
with the guilt for the rest of his life
there's a lot of mentions about like the
start 3 Treaty and nuclear
non-proliferation ideologies stuff that
is so far removed from the simplistic
toy-like arcade skill challenges of
video games from the 80s and the 90s
that westerners were more used to
music
but amidst all the Kojima craziness
there's like poignant messages
underneath it all and it just takes you
on a ride like no other it's very much a
hideo fujima game and I love it to death
[Music]
first thing the problem of mine I think
actually is the elevator scene because I
still believe that is one of the most
iconic scenes in all the video games
ever
Nick there's something I forgot to tell
you before what the ride that that
single scene takes you on is so nuts and
it's told through a codec if you take
out the one I'm wearing that leaves four
first grade math class and it's just
like literally autocon's face flipping
out look out snake
the guys who stole my stealth prototypes
are in there with you and all of a
sudden the realization that you're not
alone in that leap amazing
is so insane because the writing is so
good because the voice actors are so
good that I'm just thinking about it
right now and I'm getting like
that realization was intense and then it
just leads to a awesome fist fight with
invisible dudes in an elevator which is
just
[Music]
there are certain video games that I
think rewire your brain hello
like the first time I saw Mario 64 I was
like my brain could not process that I
was like what is actually happening
while this is taking place and I think
Metal Gear was that experience for me
that really showed me wait video games
can do this huh
that's the first time I've ever had a
video game with me like that you know
they're like hey unplug the controller
and I was like wait what
he won't be able to read your mind
if you're using the controller and
you're playing against psychomantis
there is a part where he can read all of
your attacks because he's just reading
the input on your controller
not a lot of uh video games since then
have really gone that hard with uh
tackling the fourth wall you had some
similar gimmicks happen in uh like the
Batman Arkham Asylum games
did anyone catch the game last night
[Music]
but one thing that has been a part of
the conversation since then is that if
fourth wall breaking gimmicks like that
come up again they are instantly
compared to Metal Gear Solid one because
Metal Gear Solid one had the fortune of
doing it first and uh maybe doing it
best that was the boss battle that made
me go this is why gaming can really
separate itself from film and when it
comes to storytelling and where you're
involved in it and the game can speak to
you directly and Kojima really leverages
that
um
and that was a boss battle that made me
go this is what video games are all
about this is it Chief we're here
in the commodity last year we'll be able
to see Metal Gear Solid for PlayStation
installs this October keep an eye open
for it I envy people who have not played
Metal Gear Solid one I think it is an
absolute Timeless classic it plays as
simple and streamlined as an arcade hit
from the 80s and has a Timeless story as
fascinating and intense as a 1950s
Hitchcock Masterpiece if you go back and
play Metal Gear Solid one which I've
done multiple times over the years you
are still Blown Away by just the framing
of this and how Breakneck turn page
airplane fiction spy flick one beat to
the next you can't stop playing the
whole way through now we look at it and
we're like oh yeah games to be cinematic
whatever but this dude hideo Kojima and
his team did this on a PS1 you know what
I mean it's just how it's just the
legacy of metal gear I mean it's so many
things first of all it solidify the
stealth genre it was a thing that put
stealth games on the radar be beyond
solidifying the stealth genre it moved
the technological capabilities of gaming
Kojima always just pushes the boundaries
of what a generation of consoles can
achieve and then on a narrative level he
really pushed and really utilized the
interactive nature of video games to
tell a story in a way you couldn't tell
in a movie or in a book and then from
there that set the groundwork for so
many future game developers to take
inspiration from and the legacy of Metal
Gear Solid is reflected in many of
today's games and I'm just glad that I
got to live through this era where I saw
that unfold live you know from Metal
Gear Solid all the way to metal gear
solid five it's an incredible Legacy
it's gonna leave a mark you know for
eternity I think I mean look at her
she's the best she's the best Aragon I'm
sorry buddy I really am I'm sorry Annika